joe biden's war on the unborn continues
his doj is now promising to defend women
who are pursuing illegal immigrant
illegal abortions in texas quote we will
continue to protect those seeking to
obtain or provide reproductive health
services pursuant to our criminal and
civil enforcement of the face act this
is in direct response to texas banning
abortions after a fetal heartbeat is
detected
south dakota governor christie gnome has
been fighting for the unborn unborn in
her state as well she's unveiling a big
announcement on the matter today
governor
tell us about rachel how are you doing
this evening how are you tell us about
this big announcement
well today i signed an executive order
that would ban telemedicine abortions
essentially what this would do would be
requiring in the state of south dakota
that an abortion was would only legally
be allowed in the situations defined by
our statute but also after an in-person
examination by a doctor licensed in
south dakota and obviously everybody
knows that i'm pro-life and do not
support any kind of
abortions but
here what the biden administration is
doing is trying to put forward abortion
on demand and we're going to stop them
and make sure that that's not available
in our state yeah it's so fascinating i
don't think a lot of people in america
even knew that you could obtain an
abortion via telemedicine so that's
actually very very interesting to me
another thing our audience probably
doesn't know much about is that when you
were elected to be governor you decided
that you needed someone in your
administration to represent the unborn
because they don't have a voice tell us
about that this person and what do they
do
[Music]
yeah i have a person in my office whose
job description is designated as being a
pro-life advocate as being an unborn
child advocate that every day looks for
opportunities to defend life so it may
be in putting statute putting laws on
the books it may be you know jumping
onto court cases and challenges it may
be through the regulations that come
through agencies and pushing back on the
invited administration and what they're
trying to do it's so interesting to me
rachel to listen to these the left and
the extremists how they've been
demanding for years and years that
abortions need to be between a woman and
her doctor and now essentially what
they're doing is saying that abortions
need to be available between a woman and
any stranger on the internet somebody we
don't even know if they have a license
and it's it's incredible to me what
they're saying and what they're doing
and south dakota is going to fight to
protect each and every single life yeah
well joe biden has now put his doj to go
after pro-lifers on in in light of the
heartbeat bill in texas do you plan or
your
your advocate for for the unborn in your
administration are you guys planning on
doing something similar in south dakota
we've already connected with those in
texas that brought forward this bill and
are working and looking at how we could
facilitate this legislation in south
dakota and what would be an appropriate
fit for our statute as well but i think
that was incredible to watch and to see
happen out of the supreme court and
certainly it was immediately something
that we were looking at doing here in
our state
well governor you are a champion for
life
and you have given a voice to the the
elderly the vulnerable
the unborn the disabled and um as a
mother of a special needs baby on that
that means a lot to me in particular so
thank you for all you do for life
well you are too rachel i appreciate you
sharing your testimony with everybody
about how important little valentina is
with each and every single one of your
children thank you every life matters
thank you governor
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else